even Arnold came out against Donald
Trump yeah Arnie female sir yeah Donald
in [ __ ] Annie what is Mary we're
talking about but he was nice to them as
nice a damn occasion for sausage
okay from that denouncing Trump yes they
do the voice I can no longer stand for
someone all of us come back then myself
there's a line people here just crossed
into hi okay you don't grab the [ __ ]
first of all a lot of them would let you
you just have to ask just grabbing it
was he left you like rapping president
and his gnarled are you pro Hillary I
see Hillary is a good woman
misunderstood and sometimes people when
they're around two women they wind up
suiciding themselves the personalities
it makes you humble the governor that
was our governor
[Music]